what has it been like for you waiting
for this movie to come out knowing how
good it is i know it's you know me and
the guys were talking about that earlier
that we we started production on this
four years ago we finished it three
years ago
the first trailer premiered at comic-con
in you know 2019
and
so i you know people have been asking me
they're like are you bummed that it
hasn't come out yet or all this stuff
and i think if anything i'm just glad
that it's fine it's that it's coming out
but also that it's going to be seen in
theaters because that was really
why
um you know paramount and tom were
withholding it because they they felt
like
you know we worked the movie's too good
and it's deserving of a big screen so so
at the end of the day i'm glad they
waited i'm not somebody who feels rushed
to
for anything really i'm i'll take it as
it comes i love tom cruise i think he's
the goat i think
he he's unbelievable and what he's
willing to do is uh i mean like
jaw-dropping what as an actor what was
it like working with him and like what
did you take away from his work ethic
that perhaps you've applied to future
things
i mean tom's work ethic is is unmatched
uh i heard a lot of stories about him
coming into this thing and he exceeded
all of them i really don't know
you know when people say there's only 24
hours in a day
i don't know how that's true with tom
because the amount of stuff that he's
getting done
is is just really
it's it's unreal and for this movie i
mean we really all kind of trained like
many tom cruises because we're doing all
of the
all of the stunts as they were we're
actually in the jets and the amount of
training that went into that
but kind of like what you said tom
you know he he really if you have tom
cruise's move you don't need cgi because
he's putting the audience in
in the seat next to him you know he's
really putting you right there with him
and so it's uh
i mean i can't tell you how incredibly
difficult this movie was but it doesn't
happen without somebody like tom leading
it what was it like reading in the
script when you found out you're going
to be doing a shirtless beach scene like
the original movie um and were you like
yes or were you like oh no
i think i was probably mid-eating pizza
that i immediately spit out of my mouth
and you know went on a run
uh i mean
that's the first scene is so iconic and
those guys are so
like jacked
uh but
you know i
and in the original goose is the only
one with his shirt on so they
they said
they i think they said miles like you
don't have to get in shape you know your
dad wasn't in shape and i said rooster's
not goose and i'm i'm going to get in uh
oh in in some good shape but also i
think it's
you know it just matches his character
too a little bit more i think i think
than goose i think he
yeah i think he's he's carrying a little
more weight and you know the burden and
kind of wanting to
just make so many people proud so he
seemed like a character that that
wouldn't be kind of slacking in in
all areas i'm just gonna again say um
congrats movie is really fantastic
appreciate it thanks buddy cool have a
great day